chers collègues prenaient place monsieur
le Président cher Stéphane Mesdames et
Messieurs mes chers collègues les
régions et territoires d'outre-mer sont
une richesse pour l'Union européenne
dont le territoire se trouve ainsi
étendu autour du globe bien au-delà du
seul continent européen il constitue à
cet égard de précieux atouts pour
l'Union sur le plan stratégique mais il
lui offre aussi des opportunités en
termes touristiques ou encore comme
source de biodiversité et je m'arrête
deux minutes pour dire que au président
Stéphane Artano que je suis vraiment
désolé de ne jamais pouvoir assister à
la délégation mais que nous avons notre
commission en même temps même si je suis
membre associé à cette à cette
délégation et Stéphane le sait j'ai
beaucoup d'attachement pour l'outre-mer
pour y avoir beaucoup travaillé en tant
que président des élus du littoral un
grand nombre de ces régions et
territoires font partie intégrante de la
République française sous le statut de
région
ultra périphérique les rupes ou bien de
pays étaient territoires d'outre les
PTOM et c'est pourquoi la France et
l'État membre le plus concerné par le
sort que leur réserve l'Union depuis
1999 les traités prévois précisément de
leur accorder une attention spécifique
au titre de leur éloignement de leur
insularité de leur climat de leur faible
superficie ou de leur dépendance
économique nous pourrions ajouter à
cette liste leur exposition particulière
au risque naturel et je sais de quoi je
parle pour avoir travaillé sur sur un
rapport conséquent volcan cyclone séisme
warsunami sujet sur lequel j'ai eu
l'occasion en 2019 de présenter le
rapport qu'adopter la délégation aux
outre-mer dont j'étais à leurs membres
tous ces éléments justifiés en effet que
l'Union européenne adapte ses règles en
outre-mer et apportent un soutien
constant au développement de ces
territoires grâce aux différents outils
existants c'est une conviction partagée
par la délégation sénatoriale aux
outre-mer et par la commission des
affaires européennes ce qui justifie
organisation aujourd'hui de cette table
ronde par nos deux instances de ce point
de vue nous pouvons ensemble saluer la
récente décision qui a prise la
Commission européenne c'était en février
dernier d'autoriser un régime français
de 3 milliards d'euros d'aide d'État
destiné à indemniser jusqu'en 2027 les
entreprises de 5 régions ultra
périphériques françaises pour les
surcoûts qu'elle supporte dans le cadre
des activités qu'elles exercent sur ces
territoires ce régime d'aide consiste en
une réduction de l'octroi de mer cette
taxe prélevée sur les produits importés
dans les rubbes françaises ou les
productions locales de ces dernières
nous nous félicitons qu'il puisse
contribuer au développement régional et
à la compétitivité de ces régions
toutefois sur de nombreux autres
dossiers nous semblent utile
d'approfondir les échanges avec la
Commission européenne pour mieux la
sensibiliser aux enjeux des outre-mer et
je remercie ces représentants de cette
rendue disponible ici à Paris ou depuis
Bruxelles
je ne citerai notamment madame Monica NC
qui est directrice budget communication
et affaires générales
en regioad la direction générale de la
politique régionale et urbaine de la
Commission européenne et la direction
générale partenariat internationaux de
la commission représenté par Madame
Catherine mentoningen
chef d'unité accompagné de Monsieur
Frédéric mayeur plus particulièrement en
charge des pays et territoires
d'outre-mer nous sommes notamment
désireux d'envisager avec vous la
possibilité de faire un plus grand
nombre d'usages des dispositions des
traités dédiés aux outre-mer notamment
l'article 349 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
mécaniquement l'élargissement progressif
qu'a connu l'Union rend de plus en plus
difficile la prise en compte des
réalités des rupes l'Union comprend
désormais 27 États membres dont la
plupart ignorent les problématiques des
outre-mer et l'intégration possible des
états aujourd'hui candidats situés dans
les Balkans ou sur le flanc est du
continent pourrait encore occulter un
peu plus les sujets ultramarins dans ce
contexte nous sommes particulièrement
inquiets à l'approche de la révision à
mi-parcours du cadre financier
pluriannuel de l'Union européenne et du
risque que les fonds aujourd'hui
consacrés à soutenir les outre-mer soit
réduits au nom d'autre priorités
incontestable comme la transition
énergétique ou le soutien à l'Ukraine
plus généralement nous souhaiterions
comprendre comment convaincre nos
partenaires de la nécessité d'adapter
les normes européennes aux réalités
d'outre-mer je pense par exemple à la
marque ce qui est requis sur les
produits importés dans l'Union
européenne cette exigence appliquait
dans les régions d'outre-mer les
empêchent de s'approvisionner
directement dans leur environnement
régional et conduit et conduit pour
importer des marchandises provenant
parfois d'un pays voisin aller faire
transiter par l'Union européenne c'est
ce type de décalage entre les règles et
la réalité de terrain que nous avons
collectivement intérêt à éviter pour ne
pas entraver le développement local de
ces territoires qui je le répète sont
une chance pour l'Union européenne je
cède maintenant la parole au président
Stéphane Artano qui est le mieux placé
au Sénat pour évoquer plus en détail
avec vous les réalités ultramarines
monsieur le Président cherche
Jean-François Charco lag mesdames
messieurs je remercie vivement le
président Jean-François Rapin d'avoir
pris l'initiative de réunir nos deux
instances afin d'aborder les politiques
européennes sous l'angle de nos
territoires ultramarins nous estimons en
effet que la France a une mission
particulière à cet égard car elle est la
seule à posséder à la fois des régions
ultra périphériques 6 et des territoires
des pays des territoires d'outre-mer les
PT om ils sont 6 également ceux-ci ont
fait on fait une sorte de porte-parole
des Outre-mer au plan européen afin de
faire remonter de manière transversale
les difficultés constatées dans des
territoires qui sont comme vous le savez
extrêmement variés ce n'est pas la
première fois que notre délégation se
saisit de la dimension européenne des
politiques menées dans les outre-mer en
juillet 2020 la délégation sénatoriale
aux outre-mer a adopté un rapport sur
les enjeux financiers et fiscaux
européens pour les autres mères alors
que nous étions en pleine négociation du
cadre financier pluriannuel 2021-2027
rapport dans lequel figurer une
trentaine de recommandations la présente
réunion s'inscrit d'ailleurs à nos yeux
dont le cadre du suivi de ce rapport et
de la prise en compte des sujets
d'actualité comme l'avortement préconisé
le groupe du travail de nos collègues
pascaliers notre objectif à l'époque
était de veiller à ce que l'équilibre
budgétaire pluriel ne soit pas
défavorable aux outre-mer et de mieux
faire entendre leur voix auprès des
institutions françaises et européennes
la délégation avait ainsi organisé de
nombreuses réunions et surtout un
déplacement à Bruxelles ce qui lui avait
permis d'entendre au total une
quarantaine de personnalités presque
trois ans après sa sortie et un mois du
prochain comité interministériel les
outre-mer le siome sous l'egide de la
première ministre où en sommes-nous
comme l'a dit le président Rapin nous
attendons nos invités un certain nombre
d'éclairages pour notre part les sujets
sur lesquels nous souhaitons vous
entendre mesdames et messieurs sont en
liaison avec des travaux récents menés
par la délégation gestion des déchets
continuité territoriale fonciers
agricole sur le dossier des déchets je
ne m'étonnerai pas car la commission des
affaires européennes devrait examiner
prochainement une proposition de
résolution de nos collègues Gisèle
Jourda et Viviane Mallet suite à leur
remarquable rapport sur ce sujet auquel
je vous suggère de vous reporter dans le
recommandation il y a notamment le
projet de faire du secteur des déchets
et de l'économie circulaire un des gens
prioritaire d'adaptation des normes et
des aides européennes aux réalités des
rupes conformément l'article 349 du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne dans ce même registre le
rapport appel aussi à l'adaptation du
règlement européen sur les transferts de
déchets aux contraintes particulières
des outre-mer et à l'ouverture de
discussions dans le cadre de la
convention de balle afin de conclure des
accords régionaux pour le traitement de
déchets des Outre-mer
sur la continuité territoriale on sait
que des évolutions sont également en
cours avec la réforme de l'agence de
l'outre-mer pour la mobilité la DOM et
que des annonces seront a priori faites
lors du prochain somme que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et qui est fixé au 12
juin j'insisterai donc davantage sur le
secteur agricole les rapporteurs de
notre délégation vivaient au pèse et
États-Unis que je salue ici qui
reviennent de Martinique où ils ont pris
la mesure du défi de l'autonomie
alimentaire pour ce territoire et de la
nécessité d'une revalorisation des
enveloppes communautaires à louer à
l'agriculture ultramarine via le
poséides notamment pour faire face à
l'augmentation des coûts de production
sur place il y a beaucoup été question
des ravages de la sacospirose noire en
ce champignon on présente partout aux
Antilles qui progressent de façon
exceptionnelle exponentielle
exceptionnelle et qui est à l'origine
d'une chute très importante d'étonnage
récoltés de bananes baisse de plus de
20% en 2021 mais l'usage de nouvelles
techniques génomiques
qui pourraient être une solution
nécessite un cadre juridique spécifique
qui relève de la compétence de la
commission vous nous direz peut-être si
ce cadre avance ou non la question de
l'adaptation du règlement général
d'exemption par catégorie le rgec
notamment pour faciliter et accélérer
encore la transition écologique et
numérique européenne et celle de
l'adaptation des politiques européennes
en matière de pêche sont également au
cœur des préoccupations de nos
territoires
renouvellement des flottes de pêche
notamment bien qu'autorisés par principe
par la Commission européenne en février
2022 n'est toujours pas mise en place et
nous espérons que vous en donnerez des
raisons enfin sur les fonds ferder et
FEDER la demande de simplification des
procédures d'attribution des aides est
une animement partagée pour permettre la
relance des productions voilà en
quelques mots les raisons pour
lesquelles nous sommes particulièrement
heureux d'échanger avec vous je redonne
la parole aux présidents Rapin on le
remercions une nouvelle fois pour
l'occasion qui nous est donnée de faire
ce focus européen très opportun
merci Stéphane et pour ne pas perdre de
temps puisque derrière nous avons les
questions d'actualité je vais passer la
parole tout de suite à Madame Monica
peut-être madame Monica NC
que j'ai présenté tout à l'heure et qui
va peut-être se représenter
allez-y
la voilà on vous voit très bien on vous
voit très bien et je pense qu'on va vous
entendre et on vous entend
bonjour j'espère que vous me répondez
désolé que on pourrait pas être là
aujourd'hui avec vous à Paris en fait le
train était annulé donc c'était avec un
petit peu d'urgence que je me connecte
ici à
travers de l'ordinateur donc monsieur le
Président trapan Monsieur le Président
Artano chère madame monsieur le
sénateurs je suis ravie d'être parmi
vous lors de cet arbre consacré aux
relations entre l'Union européenne et
les outre-mer de la commission des
affaires européennes de Sénat français
et la délégation sénatorale à
l'Outre-mer aujourd'hui
nous offre une excellente
occasion de discuter la stratégie
européenne pour les régions
ultra périphériques bien évidemment on
parle ici des régions français ou très
périphériques donc c'est Guadalupe
réunion Martinique Saint-Martin Mayotte
et Gayane mais aussi
qui se situe
au territoire en Amérique de Sud ou en
arabienne ou dans l'océan Atlantique
notamment madeir les
îles Canaries et aussi la soeur ces
régions font partie intégrale de l'Union
européenne et ses citoyens sont les
Européens et c'est pourquoi c'est
tellement important pour nous à la dans
la Commission européenne de s'assurer
que c'est citoyens et région c'est si
éloigné
peut profiter quand même les avantages
de l'Union européenne
ces régions ont des atouts uniques une
biodiversité très riche une situation
stratégique par exemple pour le
lancement de satellites ou la recherche
scientifique ainsi que des ondes
maritimes étendues à la proximité avec
des autres continents
la crise ukrainienne malheureusement a
réussi le coup de transport de l'énergie
et des aliments présentent un nouveau
défi pour ces régions si dépendantes des
produits et des services importés avec
notre communication donc la stratégie
qui a été déjà mentionnée adopté en main
la commission c'est pleinement engagé à
continuer à soutenir les régions ultra
périphériques nous voulons contribuer à
combler le fossé en matière de qualité
de vie en ces régions elle reste de
l'Union européenne c'est pourquoi la
politique de cohésion qui a déjà même
signé aussi aujourd'hui et aussi
important
et c'est aussi dans cet esprit que nous
allons à la rencontre de chaque région
outre-feuille que nous renforçons le
dialogue et que nous apportons le
soutien adapté la commissaire Ferreira
les affairesera viennent de lancer une
approche aussi bilatérale avec chaque
région elle va rencontrer chaque région
à son niveau
je pense en automne pendant la
conférence à des présidents des régions
outrésoriques cette nouvelle stratégie
mais les citoyens au premier plan
et vise l'amélioration de niveau de vie
l'amélioration de l'accès aux
infrastructures et au service des bases
je pense pour parvenir à cet objectif la
stratégie vise à soutenir la relance et
la croissance durable de ces régions
fondées sur le double transition bien
évidemment verte et numérique est fondée
aussi sur les atouts et potentiels de
chaque région leur stratégie est
développement pour les aider de
diversifier leurs économies et créer des
emplois et de rendre leur croissant le
plus forte et le plus durable donc la
commission bien sûr déjà commencé à
mettre en oeuvre cette stratégie et
notamment on a inscrit les priorités et
les préoccupations de ces régions donne
une grande norme de législations
européennes vous avez mentionné
l'importance de utiliser pleinement les
dispositions de l'article 389 dans la
traiter
c'est pourquoi depuis le début de la
mandat des commissaires Elisa Ferreira
on a déjà intégré ces préoccupations des
rupes dans presse de
70 univers initiatives
transportant leur spécificité juste pour
m'insigne quelques-uns par exemple la
pacte vert de l'euro
la Commission s'est engagée accordée une
attention particulière aux rues tenant
compte de leur bulnérabilité et
changement climatique et aux
catastrophes naturelles la stratégie de
l'Union européenne pour la biodiversité
là aussi la commission s'engage à mettre
accent sur la protection et restauration
des écosystèmes des régions outre
périphériques le plan d'action pour
l'économie circulaire vous avez
mentionné la question de déchets aussi
prévoir à élaborer des solutions sur
mesure pour les rupes et les îles aussi
Antonin comme de leur défi et spécifique
le transport c'est un secteur vraiment
important étant donné à la situation
géographique des cérum la proposition
sur les réseaux transs européens des
transports étant la couverture
géographique des quarts de réseau à
diverses infrastructures de transport
des rupes les rondes ainsi éligibles en
financement des mécanismes pour
l'interconnexion de l'Europe écrit des
conditions spécifiques pour les rues le
paquet législatif fuites forfait en
particulier concernant la révision des
systèmes d'échanges de quota aussi
maintiennent une exception
jusqu'à 2030 pour les vols domestiques
verts et en provenance des rues rupes
pour répondre à leurs besoins
connectivité à faciliter la continuité
territorale territoire et c'est la même
cas pour les voyages maritimes donc
voilà quelques exemples importants je
pense comment la européenne suit cette
stratégie en inscrivant les
préoccupations des rhumes dont les
propositions et la législation bien
évidemment à part des questions
législatives il y a les fonds
d'européennes et on s'assuré que dans
chaque programme compétitif les rues
possibles ils ont une opportunité
de se présenter avec les projets et de
recevoir les fonds européennes nous
sommes en train de organiser
plusieurs ateliers à une programme par
l'autre avec les interlocuteurs dans ces
régions pour les aider dans ce monde
compétitif parce que c'est on cherche
les projets excellents et pour pouvoir
monter les projets qui sont après
financiers avec les fonds européens
mais
à part de ces programmes compétitifs
bien évidemment on a les fronts
structurels et là je me réjouis de faire
que la programmation pour l'année 2021
et 27 et bien finalisé pour ces régions
et
mise en oeuvre peut commencer
par contre en ce qui concerne les fonds
de développement des Fonds européen de
développement régional pour les périodes
2014 20 en France dans les régions
ultraperies notamment malheureusement je
m'inquiète du retard important de
l'exécution financière qui bien
évidemment risque de perdre les fonds
donc j'espère que nous pouvons continuer
travaillons ensemble pour s'assurer que
les fonds européennes qui sont à vos
disposition sont bien utilisées je vais
clôturer mon intervention
en discutant un peu le futur la
commission européenne a commencé à ce
moment les consultations sur l'avenir de
la politique de cohésion nous avons créé
un groupe de réflexion au niveau qui se
réunit réuni régulièrement nous
aimerions aussi avoir des discussions
avec chaque État membre de l'Union
européenne mais aussi avec les rupes
pour s'assurer que les priorités des
rhub sont bien pris en compte aussi dans
la future politique et dans la culture
cadre financière et donc j'encourage la
France à participer à ces débat votre
vie extrêmement importante pour nous
merci beaucoup et merci pour tolérer mon
accent aussi
merci chers madame et merci de vous être
exprimé en français
je vais maintenant laisser la parole à
la DG il passe sur les partenariats
internationaux Madame Catherine
malepingen j'espère que je n'ai pas
écorché votre nom et je m'en excuse par
avance et Monsieur Frédéric Meyer
merci Monsieur Rapin Monsieur Merci
monsieur Artano merci de cette
invitation et de donner de nous donner
donc nous à la Commission et en
particulier à la notre Direction
Générale l'opportunité d'un échange sur
le dossier des pays territoires
outre-mer
je voudrais d'abord saluer le dialogue
très positif et constructif que nous
maintenant avec la France donc en
particulier sur ce dossier je voudrais
aussi remercier la France pour son
excellent travail durant la présidence
française du conseil et en particulier
pour sa contribution importante dans un
dossier assez complexe tel que la
coopération intra régionale qui est
couverte par nos associations
d'associations et sur lequel mon
collègue Frédéric parlera plus en détail
et enfin je veux surtout remercier la
France et la Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
l'organisation et participation au
récent forum Union européenne sanitaires
eau de mer outre-mer qui s'est tenu en
Nouvelle-Calédonie Nouméa en novembre
2022 et dont les résultats ont été plus
que satisfaisants j'en profite pour dire
également que nos prochains forum se
tiendra à Bruxelles mi-novembre
tout d'abord les grandes lignes
d'un partenariat Union européenne pays
et territoire outre-mer
donc ces relations entre les 13 PTOM
puisque malheureusement les 12 avant
nous étions 25 et 12
territoires britanniques nous ont quitté
le premier février 2020 donc ces
relations sont uniques et durables elles
ont des historiques profonds
puisqu'elles sont codifiées dans le
traité et ce depuis le traité de Rome de
1957 la grande différence bien entendu
avec les régions ultra périphériques
c'est que les pays territoires outre-mer
ne font pas partie du territoire de
l'Union européenne ni du marché de
l'Union donc ils ne sont pas liés par la
cucumoniothèque et ceci cela étant les
ressortissants des pays territoire
antonaires sont des citoyens de l'Union
ils ont le droit de vote aux élections
du Parlement européen les ptwm sont
politiquement très importants pour
l'Union il joue un rôle important en
tant qu'avant-poste stratégique du globe
et très important pour la promotion des
valeurs et des normes européennes donc
encore une fois malgré qu'il ne fasse
pas partie de l'Union européenne dire
qu'ils font partie de la famille
européenne
alors la relation les relations de
l'Union et des pays territoires
outre-mer régis par un cadre juridique
un cadre d'associations qui se
renouvelait qui se renouvelait depuis
plusieurs années à travers des décisions
d'associations
ces décisions d'associations
promeus à chaque fois un dialogue
politique continue avec les pays et les
États membres concernés donc la France
Danemark et des Pays-Bas
elle postule aussi un traitement
commercial préférentiel vu que les PT o
m bénéficient
en vertu de toutes ces décisions ont
bénéficié et continuent à bénéficier
d'un Duty quota fruit donc un accès un
accès libre exemple tout droit et
finalement donc les pays territoire
outre-mer bénéficient aussi d'une
coopération financière répondant aux
besoins spécifiques territoriaux et
régionaux donc la condensation ce n'est
pas qu'un accord financier c'est aussi
un accord politique et commercial cela
la différence avec les autres
instruments
de coopération internationale que nous
gérons ici à la direction générale
alors le dernier instrument bien entendu
la dernière décision la dernière
décision relative à l'association
d'outre-mer est la décision
d'associations d'outre-mer incluant le
Groenland pourquoi incluant le gros de
l'Inde parce que avant le gros de l'Inde
avait une décision supplémentaire Adobe
de type financier et que au gré des
négociations le Danemark et le Groenland
ont souhaité qu'il soit toujours fait
mention de cette particularité
particularité de leur territoire alors
que juridiquement il n'y avait bon
c'était une décision politique et son
plan juridique peut-être pas sa raison
d'être toujours est-il que voilà on
l'appelle la dawak la Doha en anglais et
c'est donc le cadre actuel qui régit une
relation pour 2021 jusque 2027
ce cadre prévoit donc une enveloppe de
500 millions d'euros
il a augmenté de 5% par rapport à la
période 2014-2020 5% sur papier
puisqu'il est bien entendu avec
l'inflation ce chiffre est peut-être un
petit peu optimiste alors les
principales composantes financières de
ces décisions sont les suivantes il y a
225 millions qui vont directement en
soutien bilatéral de notre coopération
avec le compte de laine
pourquoi autant pour le grand de l'Inde
est bien entendu tout cela s'explique
par des questions de relation historique
liées en grande partie à l'existence
d'accords de pêche tout à fait bénéfique
pour l'Union européenne je dis ça parce
que c'est important si un jour les
relations ou les accords de pêche
devraient souffrir quelques quelques
problèmes il faudrait peut-être rappeler
dans les futures négociations que c'est
important de Somme est liée donc à
l'existence d'un accord de pêche
bénéfique pour l'Union européenne nous
avons également 164 millions d'euros
sous forme de subventions pour un
soutien programme mâle bilatéral
donc pour le développement des 12 autres
PTOM donc autre que le coin de l'Inde et
nous avons une enveloppe de 76 millions
pour les programmes régionaux donc 15
millions pour une coopération intra
régionale qui est un instrument pas
tellement novateur mais sur lequel nous
essayons pour l'instant au regard de
nouvelles de nos nouvelles stratégies
politiques de mettre un peu plus en de
mettre plus l'accent mon collègue vous
en parlera
plus en détail
donc au-delà de cette décision donc qui
est centrale dans notre
notre relation avec les pétomèmes il
faut aussi rappeler que les pto-mont
accès au même titre que les
représentants des États membres à tous
les programmes européens sauf exceptions
qu'ils ont accès à eras plus horizon
Europe cosmique
mais là bien entendu ce n'est pas sous
la forme d'une
d'une enveloppe à louer Haddock mais
sous la forme de concurrence classique
donc appel à projet ils peuvent postuler
ils ont aussi accès à notre grande
instrument de coopération indique global
Europe où ils ont accès à une enveloppe
climatique et aux actions d'urgence il
reste bien entendu tout à fait visible à
l'aide humanitaire
pour l'instant nous avons une évaluation
de cette décision qui est en cours
qu'on appelle l'évaluation à mes
parcours elle est en cours donc elle
couvre tous les instruments financiers
donc en se compris la décision
[Musique]
d'association
ce rapport sera produit donc sur base
d'une évaluation indépendante par les
évaluateurs par des évaluateurs
indépendants elle sera produite disons
fin février 2024 et la consultation
publique est en ligne et il est en cours
jusqu'au 23 juin
le rapport final sera présenté devant le
Parlement européen par ailleurs je dois
mentionner également qu'il y a une
évaluation stratégique de notre
coopération avec tous les PTM qui est
prévu pour 2024 et elle couvrira
plusieurs années et sera centré sur donc
les résultats et ses impacts
la dernière évaluation stratégique
couvrait la période 99 2009
alors au sujet de l'avancement de notre
coopération à ce jour je dois dire que
nous faisons preuve d'un très très bon
niveau de mise en oeuvre de
programmation donc puisque nous avons
adopté 14 des documents de programmation
avec les ptwen donc ceci ont été adopté
en particulier pour les pays français
nous avons adopté pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie le programme sur la
transition énergétique 30 points 9
millions pour la Polynésie française un
programme sur la gestion durable de
l'eau de 31 points à million pour
Saint-Barthélémy 2.5 millions sur la
réduction des risques de catastrophes
pour les Terres australes et
antarctiques françaises 4 millions
d'euros sous la protection et la
biodiversité marine
pour s'inspirer Miquelon 27 millions sur
le tourisme durable et nous attendons
bientôt que pour Wallis photuna nous
attendons donc un adopter très
prochainement un projet de 20.4 millions
pour le développement socio-économique
durable
donc tous ces programmes donc porteront
donc sur un domaine prioritaire à Lyon
lié à l'action climatique et donc ils
mettra donc l'accent sur le Green Deal
le pacte vert de plus c'est programmes
sont en phase et priorités de la
Commission européenne qui sont actes
verts adaptation à l'air numérique
économie au service des personnes etc et
toutes ces priorités sont également en
ligne avec la nouvelle stratégie globale
Gateway et la stratégie un Pacifique
donc il est à noter aussi que la
principale modalité de mise en oeuvre
des programmes est la plus budgétaire
qui consiste à foudernir directement les
ressources financières au gouvernement
des territoires partenaires afin de
soutenir leur politique sectorielle et
de développer leur capacités
institutionnelles donc cela se traduit
par différents avantages donc d'abord il
y a une appropriation par les
territoires partenaires il y a un
renforcement de la planification de la
gestion des finances publiques il y a
une réduction des coûts transactions un
aliment sous les politiques
territoriales une certaine flexibilité
en bref une promotion de la transparence
et de leur de la redevabilité
que dire de plus peut-être un mot sur le
la stratégie
la stratégie globale Gateway
puisque c'est un terme assez nouveau est
sur lequel en général le grand public
nous demande souvent des explications
donc la stratégie globale Gateway dite
passerait le Mondial en français aussi
et simplement une stratégie de
priorisation d'investissement de nos
ressources existantes jointes ou pas à
celle des tamandre qui le souhaitent et
qui part du constat qu'au niveau mondial
nous avons un déficit d'investissement
dans des secteurs importants ces
secteurs sont le numérique l'éducation
l'énergie transport l'éducation la santé
et la recherche donc ce global Gateway
donc qui a été décidé donc par la
commission d'Anderlecht en collaboration
avec le service diplomatique le S a mis
sur la table un package de 300 milliards
afin de porter de donner de renforcer
ces secteurs nous pensons que la
coopération actuelle avec les pto-m
rentre parfaitement en ligne avec cette
stratégie qui est très très importante
et qui donnera un peu plus de visibilité
aussi au travail de l'Union européenne
qui le regrettons manque parfois
justement de cette visibilité donc il
s'agit d'un grand un grand plan Marshall
d'un grand programme d'investissement
au niveau de la région Indo Pacifique
aussi
nous sommes conscients
français donc la Nouvelle-Calédonie
Polynésie française
[Musique]
l'État et wallisé Futuna qui se trouve
donc dans cette région à dopacifique et
qui donc sont rappelés à bon escient
dans tous les objectifs de cette
stratégie qui est donc été mis sur pied
par la France et que l'Union européenne
a fait sienne donc il y a peu et donc
nous avons donc un fort intérêt à
exploiter le potentiel de cette
stratégie globale Gateway et ado à
Pacifique
pour les PT o m rappelons aussi que les
forces armées françaises sont basées en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et Polynésie
française ils ont aussi les seuls qui
peuvent intervenir rapidement dans le
cas du mécanisme de protection civile de
l'Union européenne
voilà avec ces mots je pense que je
pense qu'en conclusion avant de
peut-être passer la parole à mon
collègue qui vous parle qu'il vous dise
deux trois mots sur la stratégie intra
régionale pour laquelle la France est
intervenue de manière très concrète
donc juste un mot sur ce nouveau
instrument qui se intègre dans le cadre
de la doag donc
comme ça
vous avez entendu oui
la caméra donc je sais pas si ça a coupé
on vous a pas entendu du tout en fait
dès que ça c'est dès que ça s'est coupé
dès que vous avez commencé à parler en
fait vous avez dû faire monsieur une
interférence dans le micro qui l'a coupé
on recommence oui oui je pense qu'il
faut recommencer parce que on a rien
entendu
pour Monsieur Salman
ah d'accord d'accord sinon vous auriez
été prévenu avant
de mon côté c'était juste pour signaler
qu'on mobilise pour la première fois une
enveloppe pour les fonds la coopération
intra régionale on sait que c'est voilà
une grande marque de fabrique européenne
je pense que ma collègue de la digérer
Joe aussi
le connaissait sur le bout des doigts et
tout ce qui est de plus forte résonance
comme les programmes Athènes mais dans
le cadre de notre
partenariat et en particulier avec les
territoires d'outre-mer nous avons une
coopération qui est en tout cas qui a
toujours été beaucoup plus classique
bilatérale régional mais pas encore avec
un instrument dédié pour l'entrée
régional donc comme ma chaîne unité l'a
dit nous avons bien avancé dans la
programmation 14 sur les 16 programmes
indicatif plural qui doivent être
adoptés ont été adoptés il en manque
deux dont un qui est celui de cette
enveloppe entre régionale des dialogues
discussions déjà commencé avec les
territoires avec les États membres
concernés sur plutôt le fonctionnement
la mise en oeuvre et des premières idées
de potentiels projets donc avec PTOM et
territoire voisins ça peut être des rues
ça fait des pays ACP pays tiers ou des
organisations internationales donc là
cette année
l'objectif pour nous est d'avancer dans
les dialogues sur la mise en œuvre
pratique de cet instrument adopter le
programme indicatif uraniel d'ici la fin
d'année pour que des premières idées de
projets puissent être soumises entre la
fin 2024 et 2025 avec des mises en œuvre
qui vont s'étaler jusqu'à la fin de la
période de programmation qui est jusqu'à
en 2027 donc c'est à 15 millions d'euros
qui sont dédiés dans le cadre de la
d.o.g spécifiquement pour cette
coopération intra régionale voilà
c'était les mots sur cette enveloppe et
là du coup vous avez pas dû entendre la
conclusion de Catherine
j'avais conclu en disant qu'à l'heure du
changement climatique de la mise en
péril des écosystèmes en rappelant que
quand même les PT o.m concentre à tout
le moins en 2020 des concentrés PTOM
britannique inclus 80% 80% de
l'écosystème mondial donc des
bouleversements politiques
ostratégiques l'Union européenne reste
plus que jamais engagé auprès des pays
et territoires outre-mer
je rappelle aussi que l'Union européenne
va ouvrir bientôt enfin la Commission
européenne va ouvrir de la même manière
qu'elle a ouvert un bureau un nouvel
Calédonie nous allons ouvrir un bureau à
nuque au Groenland septembre octobre
c'est prévu
donc voilà et alors je voulais terminer
j'allais terminer en mentionnant aussi
que à Nouméa nous avions reçu une
demande de la France
que la Commission soumettent également à
un projet de communication sur les PTOM
au même titre que elle a
que nous avons déjà à la commission un
projet de une communication sur les
régions
ultra périphériques qui a été renouvelé
déjà une fois donc voilà simplement pour
vous dire que nous n'avons pas oublié
cette suggestion nous travaillons dessus
donc voilà donc je vous remercie de
votre attention et vous restez à votre
disposition pour toutes vos questions
merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup à vous de toutes ces
informations
je vais laisser maintenant la parole à
nos collègues à la fois de la délégation
et aussi de la Commission
qui veut se lancer
on a parlé on a parlé fond on a parlé
argent
différents
et je remercie aux intervenants de leur
observations
c'est comme l'impression que
à la fois comme vous l'avez dit la
présence et l'action de l'Union
européenne dans nos territoires
extrêmement importantes mais
ignorer en tout cas pas suffisamment
connu pas suffisamment
mis en valeur est-ce que vous avez la
même impression et le cas échéant
que pourrait-on faire pour mieux
valoriser cette action parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas que d'action il s'agit aussi
de valeur qui sont partagées dans dans
ces territoires
ici on va prendre une deuxième question
Joël Joël gario meslam
être deux petites questions très
concrètes enfin tout d'abord plutôt
qu'une question un commentaire bravo
d'ouvrir un bureau de l'Union européenne
au Groenland c'était extrêmement
important d'autant plus qu'on voit j'y
étais il y a un peu moins d'un an où on
voit combien la Chine est en train de de
s'impliquer sur ces terres-là on voit
aussi qu'il y a des tendances
indépendantistes qui veulent se détacher
du Danemark d'ailleurs les deux sont de
toutes évidence lié donc bravo pour ça
et ma question donc très pratique et
très concrète est-ce que dans les fonds
européens destinés aux territoires
d'outre-mer il est possible d'envisager
des programmes de longs qui pourraient
aussi être utilisable pour la création
par exemple d'alliances françaises dans
des pays avoisinants je pense un sujet
très particulier en Guyane qui est
voisin du Brésil comme vous savez et au
Brésil une très grande région
amazonienne qui est Lama pas où il n'y a
aucun enseignement de français alors que
ce serait extrêmement important pour le
développement commun et de cette région
et de la Guyane française donc est-ce
que un tel programme pour être
envisageable au sein d'un autre
programme plus important merci
président
ce président Stephen Artano mes chers
collègues mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie pour ces propos très éclairants
je voudrais souligner plusieurs des
études de la délégation ont mis on est
inadaptations normatives aux réalités
ultramarines et qui conduisent notamment
à renchérissement des coûts de
production cela a été montré pour la
construction mais pour essayer de tendre
à d'autres domaines pensez-vous qu'il
existe une volonté de prendre ce sujet
abrahal corps on élaborant par exemple
un référentiel d'équivalence qui
faciliterait les échanges commerciaux
dans les zones régionales dans un
contexte par surcroix de prise de
conscience de l'empreinte carbone
faut-il maintenir les conditions
d'échange exclusivement avec l'Union
européenne
Jean-Yves Lecomte oui merci je me lance
même si on est un ordi non je ne sais
pas si le sujet a été abordé mais en
général on aborde pas en même temps que
les autres mères alors que de temps en
temps il faut les lier je crois c'est
c'est
la question les la conjugaison des
questions migratoires du pacte
migratoire européen et des questions
ultra marines
pour ce qui nous concerne la France un
certain nombre de territoires et
départements d'outre-mer ne sont pas
dans l'espace Schengen
et finalement en fait c'est comme si sur
ces sur ces territoires rien de ce qui
est négocié au niveau européen en
matière de pactes il migration on était
valable sur ces c'est ces territoires
qui sont aussi des territoires européens
et et et ma question elle est un peu
liée à cela je vois par exemple que sur
la Guyane par exemple ou Mayotte Eurodac
n'est pas appliquée c'est-à-dire que
finalement en fait
parce que ce sont des territoires qui ne
sont pas dans l'espace Schengen
et
je trouve finalement assez inadéquat de
continuer à réfléchir sur ces sujets
comme si finalement ceux qui étaient
outre-mer sur ces questions là n'était
pas liées à nos engagements et à nos
évolutions européennes
de voir que par exemple il faut pour les
Brésiliens un visa pour arriver en
Guyane alors qu'il faut pas arriver il y
a pas besoin d'un visa pour arriver dans
l'espace dans l'Union européenne il y a
un certain nombre de questions comme ça
qui mériteraient d'être revu je pense
aussi à la manière dont la France refuse
finalement d'utiliser Eurodac alors que
il y a des personnes qui rentrent sur le
territoire français en outre-mer même si
ça n'oblige engagerait pas la même les
mêmes choses en ce qui concerne les
procédures Dublin ce serait finalement
assez logique d'utiliser le dispositif
européen que nous avons sur l'ensemble
du territoire européen fustent outre-mer
pour pouvoir suivre et enregistrer les
personnes qui rentrent sur notre
territoire plutôt que de laisser chaque
pays développer ses propres petites
politiques parfois en inadéquation avec
le droit européen
merci
je bon voilà enfin le premier cycle de
questions est passé je sais pas comment
vous voulez voir organiser pour répondre
en fonction des des questions qui ont
été qui ont été posées
donc il y avait la question comment on
met en valeur tous les travail que la
Commission fait en faire dans ces
territoires je suis tout à fait d'accord
que nous devons travailler plus sur le
dialogues sur la communication sur
l'écoute des besoins locales c'est
pourquoi dans notre stratégie aussi on
s'engage justement d'avoir plus
des rencontres des avec des autorités
locales régionales les sociétés civile
la jeunesse chaque fois que maintenant
qu'on voyage en ce territoire
au niveau commissaire au directeur au
chef d'unité on rencontre aussi la
jeunesse qui joue une rôle important
nous avons aussi monté quelques projets
qui nous pensons vont aider cette
visibilité et dialogue
on est en train de de lancer un projet
de
les projets financiers avec des fonds
européens bien sûr cofinancer par par la
France et je pense que ces types des
actions aident la compréhension mais
aussi nous aide écoutez et comprendre
mieux les besoins donc c'était une des
questions que je voulais répondre la
question de Schengen bien sûr à la
question de Schengen c'est une
compétence
aussi
nationale donc l'effet que ces régions
sont pas le Schengen c'est pas une
décision de la Commission européenne et
effectivement
ça a le comme conséquence que par
exemple il peut pas utiliser Frontex ou
certains fonds pour qui sont visés
seulement pour les territoires qui sont
qui font partie de Schengen mais au
niveau européen quand même on donne
beaucoup de fonds qui peut être utilisé
dans ces territoires pour la migration
pour
réintigration
des migrants ou même la réception des
migrants y compris les jeunes non
accompagnés donc je pense que de notre
côté on fait ce que nous pouvons faire
pour aider certains régions qui sont
objets d'une grande influxe migratoire
des ténèques des situations économiques
et politiques des régions où il se situe
donc voilà je pense que je répondu aux
deux questions
j'ai dans la parole à ma collègue de
infa
oui bonjour désolé on a changé
d'ordinateur parce qu'on a été coupé
vous m'entendez
très bien voilà ok donc
j'ai cru comprendre que les questions
étaient essentiellement pour les routes
donc je vais peut-être te répondre sur
la question du plan de communication il
doit y avoir peut-être une question que
j'ai pas compris puisque on a été coupé
vous me le direz après donc le plan de
communication oui c'est vrai il y a
il y a pas beaucoup de communication les
pays territoire outre-mer malgré que ils
sont obligés au titre de la convention
de financement au titre de nos échanges
ils sont obligés de communiquer sous
l'origine des fonds européens c'est
c'est le bas qui blesse dans notre
coopération pas que sur les ppom je
pense que c'est un c'est un souci pour
la coopération en général et et voilà de
la aussi cette idée de
voilà d'imaginer ce global Gateway qui
est un plan d'investissement mais qui
est aussi un plan de communication
beaucoup plus agressif je pense qu'il
est enclunion se fasse peut-être
respecter aussi dans tout ce qu'elle
finance sur les pays en particulier nous
avons maintenant décidé de te dire une
grande partie des fonds de notre
assistante technique sur un plan de
communication beaucoup plus
ambitieux et que nous sommes en train
d'élaborer donc à l'occasion tout ça
sera discuté nous avons des triparties
des forums à travers lequel nous nous
discutons de ça avec les États membres
et les ppm mais nous allons développer
un plan de communication adopte pour les
dépôts indépendants du problème général
de communication encore une fois je le
répète qui n'est pas satisfaisant ça
voilà
je sais pas s'il y avait d'autres
questions parce qu'on a été coupés
tu veux reposer ta question
ma question était plus destinée aux
régions ultra périphériques sur les
inadaptations normatives aux réalités
ultra-marines qui conduisent à un
renchérissement des coûts de production
et qui a été montré par exemple pour la
construction et qui pourrait s'étendre à
d'autres domaines donc je voulais savoir
s'il existe une volonté de prendre ce
sujet à bras le corps on élaborant par
exemple un référentiel d'équivalence qui
faciliterait les échanges commerciaux
dans les zones régionales j'en veux pour
exemple le bois de construction entre le
Brésil et la Guyane doit traverser
l'Atlantique pour être estampillé aux
normes européennes pour revenir en
Guyane où on demande aussi dans les dans
la construction fut venir du bois de
Scandinavie qui n'est pas adapté
au climat
Antilles donc c'était dans ce dans ce
cadre là
et puis aussi la prise en compte donc de
l'empreinte carbone et qu'il faut
faut-il maintenir ces conditions
d'échange exclusivement avec l'Union
européenne
oui merci effectivement c'est plus une
question destinée au RUP pour les ppm ce
que je répondrai plutôt par enfin je
suis pas une experte de droit commercial
surtout que ces est assez complexe avec
les ptols simplement je peux vous dire
donc que tous leurs produits à part les
produits de la pêche du Groenland qui
répondent au protocole 33 du traité tous
ces produits entre beauty côte à Free
on a souvent des questions
ils veulent c'est vrai que les rupes ont
des traitements parfois un peu plus
préférentiels que les pétoèmes auxquels
aspire souvent les pétoèmes en disant
voilà nous on voudrait avoir la même
chose que c'est très compliqué pour nous
on ne peut pas simplement parce que
encore une fois il n'y a pas le seul
article qui prévoit des cadres
d'exception pour les rupes il est
inscrit dans le traité les pétouanes
n'ont pas n'ont pas cet équivalent dans
le traité donc c'est très très difficile
mais bon il bénéficient déjà d'un
échange tout plus qu'avantage sur les
normes techniques rien ne s'oppose rien
ne s'oppose à ce que un pétrole demande
un
candidate pour un projet de de
coopération commerciale dans lequel il
pourrait par exemple travailler sur
l'amélioration de non technique et nous
n'avons pas eu ce genre de demande
encore à ce jour voilà
peut-être
peut-être je vais essayer aussi répondre
donc parce que j'ai bien compris que
maintenant c'est une question sur les
sur les rues donc effectivement
conscient de fait qui il y a des
difficultés parfois qu'on nous
réglementation européenne des mondes une
certification ou le Marx ce n'importe
quel certification pour l'importation
nos seins aux lignes européennes et
quand le l'autorité qui donne cette
certification se trouve au continent et
donc effectivement un produit spécifique
comme vous avez expliqué doit traverser
l'océan et après revenir je sais qu'il y
a les discussions qui sont menées qui
sont en cours par exemple
on sait ce qui concerne les directives
européennes sur l'énergie renouvelable
vous allez directive où il y a les
contenus de chaque produit qui est de
l'énergie renouvelable au nom elle est
beaucoup de questions scientifiques et
là la question des rues de questions
spécifiques
discuter donc je sais pas quelle est la
conclusion de cette discussion non mais
je vais me renseigner et aussi on a
toujours présente aussi à par écrit si
vous pouvez élaborer à votre question on
va aller à la recherche de la réponse
plus spécifique
Annick Pétrus souhaiter poser une
question
oui bonsoir à tous
ma question est la suivante vous venez
d'évoquer une possibilité pour les
jeunes des territoires
rupes de pouvoir être aidé par les fonds
européens pour monter un projet un
projet impactant pour leur territoire ma
question est la suivante généralement
lorsque un jeune a un projet et pour les
entendre très souvent je sais que il y
en a beaucoup et que les projets sont
intéressants le problème c'est le prix
financement nous savons tous que
l'Europe ne préfinance pas ce jeune qui
a un projet intéressant que ce soit pour
lui ou son territoire n'a pas la
possibilité de préfinancer ce projet en
attendant
enfin j'ai envie de dire le
remboursement de l'Europe est-ce qu'il y
a quelque chose de prévu
pour que ce jeune là puisse monter son
projet en sachant qu'il n'a pas les
fonds de départ est-ce que ça pourrait
être un pré-financement par sa
collectivité territoriale par son
territoire est-ce que c'est possible et
est-ce que vous au niveau de l'Europe
vous avez une solution qui pourrait
aider un jeune à monter un projet un
jeune qui évidemment n'a pas d'argent au
démarrage comme ça
donc le projet sur la jeunesse donc on a
déjà lancé une appel à proposition pour
l'instant on cherche une organisation
dans plusieurs organisations dans
plusieurs rues ou pas mais avec
l'expertise dans les rues avec qui on
peut monter ce projet cette organisation
de ces organisations
doivent co-financer notre action mais ce
sera le moine possible le moine et
s'assurer que c'est vraiment la
cofinancement c'est le minimum requis
par notre réglementation de je pense que
il s'agit des 5% nos quelque chose comme
ça de ce projet une fois que on a trouvé
une partenaire ou plusieurs partenaires
avec qui on va travailler on espère bien
que
avant avant l'été au thon on lance
l'appel aux propositions des jeunes des
jeunes et là je vous assure il n'a pas
question qu'on va demander les jeunes
après financer donc ils vont recevoir je
pense en 500.000 euros peut-être plus ça
dépend de projet pour développer leur
projet
il s'agit des jeunes vraiment les jeunes
il peut être aussi les enfants
légalement donc 16 ans 17 ans bien
entendu dans ces cas-là on espère qu'une
professeure ou l'enseignant ne va aussi
participer pour s'assurer quand même que
le fonds européens sont bien mis à la
disposition de ce projet
merci
d'autres d'autres questions
dans la foulée de ce que vient de dire
notre collègue de Saint-Martin sur le
prix financement là c'était les jeunes
mais parfois les collectivités
elles-mêmes ont des problèmes de
préfinancement et c'est parfois
des difficultés pour consommer les
crédits européens il y a une solution
qui a été condamnée par les Chambres
régionales des contes qui consistait
lorsque on recevait des fonds
européennes
à faire qu'une convention de mandats
financiers notamment les sociétés
d'économie mixte des CM
préfinancel opération notamment lorsque
les collectivités ont des difficultés
lorsque les communes sont en déficit et
sur la base de l'appel d'offres
d'une convention passée avec les CM on
pouvait mobiliser des crédits bancaires
ça a été condamné par les journal des
comptes en disant c'est une activité
bancaire illégale
[Musique]
contre la Guadeloupe et la Dominique
entre la Dominique et la Martinique
entre la Martinique et Sainte-Lucie
ensuite les conventions de pêche ça
relève de la compétence de l'Europe là
aussi
certains pêcheurs se font à raisonner et
c'est un vieux problème qui n'est
toujours pas réglé même chose en matière
de coopération judiciaire en policier
bon pour les démonstrations et les
exercices faits par les armées ok mais
sur le judiciaire on a des difficultés
sur par exemple avoir des officiers de
liaison dans ces pays-là alors que
aujourd'hui on est membre de l'eau ECS
l'Organisation des États de la Caraïbes
orientale mais on a on n'a pas on a des
difficultés en disant que nous
appartenez à la France c'est à la France
à régler ça la France nous dit mais non
l'Europe ne veut pas pour délimiter les
frontières ça relève d'une compétence
nationale les conventions de paix ça
relève de compétences de de l'Europe on
a le vrai problème et puis ce que le
compte a évoqué c'est un vrai sujet cela
étant
il faut voir comment le faire Mayotte on
vient de l'évoquer avec Dany un moment
c'est un vrai sujet et si on devait
aller plus loin les prix fait la barre
en plus de pouvoir que les préfets
hexagonaux notamment en matière de
reconduite à la frontière
et en termes de rétention administrative
personne ne soulève ce problème mais si
on devait l'opposer je peux vous dire ça
poserait de vrai difficulté pour les les
parlementaires que nous sommes voilà
alors réponse
qui veut répondre
de cofinancement donc
les rues dans les régions préférés dans
la plupart des cas à bénéfice d'une
confédancement des exigences de
confinement beaucoup plus bas que les
autres régions donc c'est vrai pour les
les
structuelles donc c'est les fonds qui
sont mises en oeuvre par les États
membres c'est aussi vrai pour plusieurs
programmes compétitifs donc c'est les
programmes gérés directement ici
à Bruxelles
ou les rupes doivent postuler et ils
sont en concurrence avec les autres
régions mais si ils gagnent un projet le
taux des co-financement pour eux sera
moi élevé donc l'Union européenne va
payer une plus grande partie et les
moteurs de projet dans les rues ont
beaucoup moins partie en plus nous avons
monté une onde des instruments d'urgence
tout d'abord
pour la réponse de la crise covid après
en ce qui concernait les réfugiés donc
c'est commencé avec les fusées
Ukrainiens mais c'était aussi discuter
et aussi inclus les autres réfugiés
situés en des autres pays et finalement
en ce qui concerne l'énergie à abordable
donc on a
intrigué les flexibilité en utilisation
les fonds de coalition des fonds
structurelles ou le prix financement se
montre 100% et les cofinancements
demandés des régions et des États
membres et déduits et devient moins
élevé donc c'est flexibilité qu'on a
demandé plusieurs fois des états m'ont
bien compris la France de l'utiliser
parce que c'est aide en fait de de
dépenser l'argent comme j'ai dit il y a
un problème d'exécution financière avec
des siphones et ses Flex ibilité
aide à utiliser cet argent plus vite et
dans les délais juridique donc il y a
quelques flexibilités qui sont toujours
disponibles pour avoir 100%
pré-financement et une taux moins élevée
des confinement
en question des juridiques
internationales je suis désolé mais je
suis pas compétent de c'est un projet un
simple question très complexe en ce qui
concerne les zones exclusives maritimes
c'est la loi internationale donc je
pense pas que je vais répondre à cette
question ici des autres
c'est un peu compliqué toujours de
répondre par rapport aux rues parce que
sont des cas juridiques tellement
différents voilà simplement pour cette
question de préfinancement et de
facilité d'accès au fond pour démarrer
des projets quand on est dans le travail
dans le cadre de projet alloué donc un
territoire
quel qu'il soit impétueux quel qu'il
soit dès que ça convention de
financement elle est signée il a il a
accès directement à un système de
tranche fixe suivi après par des
tranches variables qui est le propre
donc de l'aide budgétaire donc là il y a
pas à proprement parler ils vont pas
mettre de fond de la même manière quand
un privé entre guillemets donc un
citoyen dans un pays territoire
outre-mer
participe à un appel à proposition au
même titre qu'un État membre ce qui est
déjà très avantageux dans n'importe quel
projet programme de l'Union européenne
il postulent il doit pas mettre de
financement non plus à la signature
voilà il y a des avances qui sont
données par par la commission donc je ne
vois pas a priori chez nous un problème
d'accès auprès financement dans le cadre
de nos actions de coopération voilà
je vais juste peut-être apporter mon
expérience en tant qu'ordonnateur à
l'époque où je précise des ma
collectivités puisque nous sommes à
saint-pierre-et-cambetom effectivement
vous je vous rejoins tout à fait sur les
tranches fixes et variables mais parfois
pour impulser et enclencher un projet il
nous arrivait de faire appel à du prêt
financement bancaire en attendant le
versement des tranches voilà ce qui nous
permettait simplement de pouvoir
enclencher un processus et peut-être
c'est peut-être cette difficulté que
pointer du doigt victorinurel
effectivement c'est le préfinancement
nécessaire dans l'attente du versement
d'étranges qui peuvent être décalés dans
le temps au regard des contraintes des
territoires si on prend une contrainte
de saisonnalité sur un projet
d'investissement on peut te ramener
effectivement à bousculer le calendrier
notamment de la convention de
financement et on trouve du relais
notamment au niveau bancaire par du
crédit relais je dirais de type
classique me semble-t-il
merci il y a d'autres interventions non
bah écoutez je n'en vois pas merci merci
de votre disponibilité mesdames et
messieurs de nous avoir accordé ce temps
nécessaire pour essayer de comprendre
cette organisation Rupe et PT o om
peut-être
renouvel l'occasion de renouveler
cette opération mais en tout cas la
coopération entre nos deux structures
est importante tant je l'ai dit en
propos liminaire l'Union européenne a
besoin aussi de l'outre-mer et c'est
important de de signaler au travers des
petits événements comme comme cela je
vous remercie
bon après-midi
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation avec
plaisir